welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka batman and robbing
scoops from comicbook.com so i can make
videos on them cinemacon has just
happened and at the event not only was
the spider-man no way home trailer
revealed but we also got some brand new
footage for the batman june and the
matrix 4. in case you don't know
cinemacon is for industry insiders only
and pretty much allows theater chain
members in the press to get their first
look at upcoming films i haven't done a
big batman breakdown in a while but we
now know what was shown at the event and
also have some great descriptions from
people that attended it i will of course
be going through it all but if you enjoy
the video then please throw your best
batarang at that like button and make
sure you subscribe as it's always going
to be nice to see you at the channel
now brandon davis of comicbook.com stay
that the footage shown was mainly
through a featurette that kind of talked
about the movie and batman in general
similar to the one we saw at dc fandom
this had matt reeves opening it up
whilst describing what was going on he
said that his take on batman is
something that's dark and grungy and
this is something that the first trailer
definitely backed up we of course had
the music throughout it being played by
nirvana a grunge band so they are they
are really going grungy with it also did
anyone else hear that the kid who was on
the cover of the nirvana album never
mind is also suing the band for using
his image should have known that kid
would always be chasing the dollar eh
[Music]
now footage then lit up the screen and
pattinson stated that batman had been an
iconic character that stood as one of
the major figures of the 20th century
lauren huff from entertainment weekly
said that when discussing the part that
he stated from the first conversation i
had with matt about it i just knew there
was something radically different here
we then got shots of him in the suit
removing the cowl with reeves coming in
to say that things would be completely
different to what's come before reeves
referenced the seminal graphic novel
year won by frank miller and said that
this is batman in his early days filled
with rage and learning his ways ew said
that reeves described the character as
being very far from perfect
he very much wanted to enforce the point
that batman is very much a
criminological experiment which is a
word that i've just learned now now what
it basically means is that bruce is
basically carrying this out to find out
if it's possible to have a symbol that
helps to change gotham for the better
films like joker showed how people's
minds and perceptions of what they live
in could be altered with a figure to
rally behind and the dark knight trilogy
was of course based on the idea that
batman could be a spearhead this is why
bruce ended up passing things over to
harvey dent who we all know ended up
being used as a lie in order to make it
seem like gotham had a white knight
someone that people could be like this
eventually ended up leading to that lie
being exposed and thus batman returned
as a symbol once more after his
courageous sacrifice at the end of the
dark knight rises spoiler alert he's not
dead now unlike the dark knight trilogy
reeves said that bruce realizes that
batman isn't really having the effects
that he should criminals aren't running
scared and terror in fact escalates in
the area when murders start to happen
which we know are carried out by the
riddler this opens up a whole world of
corruption bruce is completely unaware
of and it's even possible that the wanes
are tied to it the trailer of course
ended with a riddler taunting bruce that
he was linked to it too and from what
i've heard on the film the wings aren't
the way that they've been portrayed as
in the past the twist of them being bad
is something that's appeared in a lot of
modern takes from the telltale games to
the joker according to what i've been
told they're gonna be shown as basically
politicians that starve the people of
gotham in order to line their pockets
bruce discovering this is what sets him
on a path to right the wrongs of the
past and he realizes that he must do
better and change the legacy that they
left behind according to huff reeve said
it's a detective story that's incredibly
personal so this idea of the waynes
being involved does make a lot of sense
from what i've heard on people close to
the film the riddler will very much be
an outcast in gotham that has decided to
clean up the corruption within it and
this is why he's carrying out
high-profile murders on people like the
mayor and d.a this is something that we
saw in batman earth 1 vol 2 and the
riddler was sort of an anti-hero who was
committing crimes for the greater good
of gotham now over the top of this we
could catch batman mercilessly beating
people up in a dark prison set with a
shining red light over the top of it i
absolutely love this idea of batman
being very unhinged and from the first
look it seemed like the character was
very much obsessed with being in this
persona in prior batman movies we've had
a lot of balance between the bruce wayne
and batman personalities but here it
seems like he's just completely focused
on being the dark knight we have seen
something similar in not only the earth
1 storyline but also in the new 52 run
by scott snyder both were filled with
b-boy pretty much casting bruce to the
side so that he could focus solely on
being batman however by the end of the
work he realized how important it was to
have balance so that people would stop
asking questions and also that he had a
way to infiltrate the gotham elite
through other means most importantly it
was just great for his mental health and
instead of hanging around in the cave
all day or running on rooftops at night
he did have an outlet now it has been
said that the film will focus heavily on
batman's mental health and that it won't
paint him out as some amazing hero
instead he will be conflicted and though
he's pretty much you know a good guy
from what i've been told there'll also
be a strong argument that he's a
complete psychopath this was of course
reflected in his most famous villain the
joker and his solo movie now i'm not
saying yet before you start yet i'm not
saying that arthur fleck was a good guy
quite the opposite but he very much
represented a person that people could
rally behind and in that story at least
he was painted out as the hero of it
even though the argument exists that
he's not which yet again i'm not saying
arthur is a good guy stop the hashtag
heavy spoilers over party now from here
on we apparently got several explosions
police officers and chaos spilling out
into gotham pattinson said he's really
working out his rage and that all the
fights are personal according to what
we've shown we could catch him brutally
beating people with numerous weapons
including pipes and he smashed their
heads in like you should smash that like
button go on do it
now this was all pretty much shown in
the first trailer but cinemacon did drop
an exclusive look at alfred who davis
described as a classy looking gentleman
wearing a vest over his shirt they've
kept the bottle mans look close to the
vest butterman and we still haven't seen
him but there's a couple of fan images
out there that could potentially show
exactly what he looks like we now have
it confirmed that he will have white
hair so yeah just just look at these and
imagine that it's real now from here the
attendees were shown some shots of the
batmobile driving and there were flames
coming out of the exhaust that was
pretty much all we got but i think it's
you know we can take a lot from this and
they're clearly trying to establish this
world that's very dark and gritty now
what i love about this is that they are
definitely hammering home the idea that
batman might be a psychopath he's gonna
be completely different to what we've
seen before and this will probably be
the darkest take that we've ever had
rather than painting him out as a hero
we're gonna see the complexity of his
character and the mental struggles that
would come with being this kind of
person i'm super hyped for obviously and
it feels good to be back doing batman
stuff i'm really hoping that the movie
doesn't get delayed and that come the
4th of march 2022 that we can all go to
the cinema and see this film in its full
glory now i'd of course love to hear
your thoughts on the teaser and what you
want to see in the film make sure you
comment below and let me know and just
to let you know we're running a
competition right now and giving away
three mcu box sets on the 30th of august
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the footage description we pick the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now say that to you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want some meals to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the spiderman no way home trailer which
will be linked on screen right now it
was trending at number two in the world
i couldn't believe it and i just want to
thank you guys for for all the support
and for listening to me drone on about
the tiny most minuscule things in a
comic book movie i really appreciate it
and if not then thank you for sitting
through this video i've been paul you've
been the best and i'll see you next time
take care peace
oh